One thing we can do to find the line of best fit, is to find the line that
minimizes the sum of all the residuals. The only problem is that the residuals
are either negative or positive. And so, if we add something like this, say.
These negative and positive residuals. Would just balance each other out. We
could have a line of best fit that doesn't go through the points at all, but
still has a very small sum of the residuals. We're kind of in the same
situation where we were figuring out how to measure spread. We looked at
possibly the average absolute deviation then, from the mean. Similarly, we
could look at the absolute residual. In other words, even if the residual is
negative, just look at the positive value. This is one method. But the standard
method is to minimize the sum of squared residuals. In other words, we'll
square all the residuals to get rid of the negative sign. Add up all these
squares. And then minimize this value. In symbols, this would be the observed y
value minus the expected y value. Which, you remember, was y hat. And this is
the y value that corresponds to that x value. On this regression line squared.
When we have a function, we can use calculus to find the maximum value and the
minimum value. When we say value, we mean the x value. Where does the max or
min occur? In other words, at what x value? We can also use calculus to
minimize this sum of squared residuals. And find out what our aggression
coefficients should be. When we use calculus, we get that our slope is equal to
this. This is a long tedious equation and you won't have to use it. It just so
happens that this is equal to r. Remember Pearson's correlation coefficient?
Times the ratio of the standard deviation of the y values to the standard
deviation of the x values. Isn't that awesome? Let's use it to find the slope
our regression line for the airplane example.